[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
let's give them the real thing to start
us off
that's it it's friday that's how we're
coming into friday break room welcome
everybody to the break room the new
rockstars live show coming to you
directly from our offices here in los
angeles uh our actual break room we're
bringing you the nerdy nummies so much i
feel like they're not buying it anymore
right this is really our break room guys
for real we're allowed to be here
there's nothing in here that makes it
look like a normal breakfast
rather than it being a set we lie in
cesar break room it's actually a break
room we hide to make it look like a set
kind of but um we're thrilled to have
you here today this is going to be a
weird fun show i'm joined uh as i often
am by uh brandon the brain barrack oh
big brain on brain dude
we got sarcastic we got uh jessica
cranium clemens oh my head's so good
and of course uh philip the mind molina
why did mine not have consonants
alliteration mind molina yeah
philip the mind molina he's bobby the
brain barrack
robbie brandon
is your best
finally the secret's out
who can read off a prompter uh coming up
today on the break room we're gonna be
doing a lot of fun stuff we're gonna be
talking about
namor news
uh is arthur harrow really dead question
mark we got from kenobi updates
exclamation point
it's
morbid oh baby oh it's such morbid time
here and uh in honor of that we're gonna
meme out here during the show um i love
it speaking so when we say it's morbid
time if somehow you've not been paying
attention morbius is getting brought
back into theaters
adding screens this movie's been out
since the beginning of april
yes
well yeah it felt like it was it was
originally going to come out in 2020 the
first movie was a train heading towards
the camera and then it was more yes yeah
that was the second one that pulled into
morbius yeah yeah yeah i uh real quick i
just want to say has a studio ever
misread pop culture more right this
moment it makes me think of snakes on a
plane which everyone was so hyped for as
a meme this was almost like pre-modern
meme yeah but then when the movie came
out and i was like well i don't want to
actually see it yeah we don't care but
the concept of get these [ __ ]
to me i think it's a little bit of like
somebody high up at sony like read a
tweet that's like i heard we made a
billion dollars at the box office i
think we should go back yes
they see well it's like they don't have
their irony lenses exactly right and
they're like people are demanding a
sequel we should put this movie i mean
they were smart with like the twitch
stream that was like just 12 hours of
more race that's what they needed they
needed like it's going to play in
theaters for 24 hours straight and it's
free and just come on yes or like add
extra footage or something it's
different yes right yes
true thing
it's really happening they are putting
it back we checked the theater that is
right down the street from our office
has a 10 p.m showing both tonight and
tomorrow night each night this weekend
know where to find zach yes well
here's what we're gonna do folks okay
the chat redemption today we already
appreciate a couple folks throwing in
some uh some doubloons some dinero in
the super chats we appreciate you
if we hit
a hundred dollars in super chats okay
and in every subsequent hundred dollars
the redemption is we have an inside
scoop here at new rockstars okay we know
that they're not just releasing the same
version of morbius
in fact they have added songs to the
soundtracks there's going to be brand
new soundtrack songs on the morbius that
is playing in the theaters this weekend
uh and we have those tracks now we just
have lyrics we're going to reproduce
those lyrics turns out also the tracks
are kind of weird al esque parodies a
very popular song i don't know why they
did this i don't know
i don't know but i have them here
they're steering into the memes and so
will we so you're going to put sound to
lyrics out of your mouth but are you
avoiding the word are you guys singing
yeah oh there will be singing there will
be singing
daniel day lewis the musical
there will be songs songs might be
bloody we don't know in fact they
probably will be because it's more be as
themed so if you want to hear uh brandon
and jessica are gonna use their musical
talent to recreate these songs for you
live on the air but the only way you get
to hear those is if you can throw a
couple bucks in the super chat again
when we hit 100 bucks we'll break one
out also we've never heard them but no
two so for if you want us to be able to
hear well it's because i can't afford a
lawyer after i release this stuff some
of these songs are dressed up as
janitors we snuck into sony music too
elaborate already
we took
we cleaned the place
right before we left we stole some stuff
we're also gonna jump into some actual
memes later uh in honor of uh it's
morbid time um but first
let's get into some headlines yeah
news news news uh this is an interesting
piece of news now there's been this
long-running kind of rumor un un kind of
certified this actor uh tanakh huerta i
believe i'm pronouncing his name's close
uh so there's this ongoing thing that
he's been cast in black panther too and
the big rumor is he's playing namor they
refuse to acknowledge that or confirm
that nobody has said that officially but
he did an interview with vice
uh jessica you were reading through this
there's a lot of interesting stuff in
there he yeah it's a this vice article
is really more about
him being
mexican and working through hollywood
and just like overcoming everything
that's in hollywood and trying to be
like recognized as more than what he was
in um the oscar-winning movie
there's only one was it like
um it was on netflix and it was really
good it was really rough was he in roma
uh yes oh okay so um he wants me more
than that and
i just think this piece was so
important and so wild about him being on
the carpet and they have to have a uh
handler basically a handler that tells
him to stop talking too much about black
panther too is there do we have a
picture of this guy or anything uh oh
the actor yeah i don't think we have
that asset i'm gonna pull it up on my
phone but yes yeah he's he's a handsome
gentleman that you could definitely
picture being shirtless uh diving into
water um okay yeah but it's funny that
the amount
they are like protecting him they're
also it came out in the article he
learned mayan oh yeah he learned mayan
to make sure that he could play the role
which is interesting but it's not a
spoken language anywhere i don't think
confirmed that they've cast him right or
is he confronted it's like this is
things like this is
can you see that you got to get real
close in there so this is how we add
assets that's not quite fgq but somebody
already did mock him up
as name on
yeah he looks too uh goblin looking no
they haven't announced that he's in the
movie they haven't announced uh yet that
he's in the movie and honestly black
panther is coming closer and closer if
he studied mayan if he has an a that's
like just don't talk about it it's like
what are you guys doing and we saw we
saw the swag gifts that had like a
little mayan figure yeah are you good
have you guys talked about this thing of
how the kind of repurposing of the
atlantis mayan we talked about a little
bit it does seem a little strange
because if i remember like comics
correctly atlantis was more attached to
africa than it was to like hence the
traditional rivalry between the
atlanteans and the uh uh wakandans yeah
i think though that from just like the
the business perspective of it right is
they saw the way that black panther
activated like the african support like
but literally africa like uh where i it
was kind of actually a little weird
where it was like we should be doing a
lot more than just making movies set
there but i i guess they're trying to
like do the same thing for latin america
which is obviously a huge part of the
world it and since these uh titles are
already connected you know it makes
sense that they would i'm like into it
it's
gonna be like a little awkward for me
because i'm like
i'm also just a normal guy that is
hispanic and i live in california and so
for you to bring me into the mcu like in
a bigger way it's like what if you're
some sort of ancient special people that
come to the bottom of the ocean floated
back up whatever like it's a little like
okay well we could just also set it in
like l.a you know like something in a
light hispanic character and you know
with um uh i'm forgetting the
character's name but from falcon winter
soldier the kind of the the secondary
kind of yeah that that guy kind of
inherits the falcon roll we think maybe
after sam wilson kind of gets the maybe
there would be some like uh latinx
characters
well there's america chavez now yeah
yeah i just kind of mean like like for
such a massive population to be like the
only way to have more than one of these
characters is you have to find this
underwater
and it's like i don't know
from underwater
the only thing in burbank is sony
headquarters where me and brandon here
stole the lyrics too yeah after doing a
full
crane
those windows
you could get these songs if you donate
you do the work
uh speaking of other marvel properties
uh moon knight director mohammad diab uh
teased kind of like
some interesting stuff with the ethan
hawk arthur harrow character he's kind
of asked and we were talking about this
right before we started filming like
wait so what are the rules about
when characters human characters versus
avatars how can they die whatever did he
you know how was he killed there at the
end of that final episode and the
director responded are you sure he's
dead um
in that classic kind of ambiguous uh way
hint hint maybe give me come back
please
i feel like that's a slap in the face
we literally started to get shot it's
the thirsty thespian thing that we're
doing but it's the thirsty director in
this case but it's like yeah but also i
applaud moon knight moon knight is the
show that is trying really hard to make
sure they can get a second season and
they're different people like it's like
these are all poc like director dp and a
lot of the writers in the room and it's
not like they're always asked to come on
like hawkeye and these people have not
are not from previous mcu properties
none of these actors right also i think
ethan hart famously a nice guy maybe
this director's like i want a second
season and i want ethan to come back
because i like hanging out with him you
know to be honest like yes right like in
like people like you can talk a lot but
i i just don't want that villain again
yeah and it feels like we got that story
told right we had that story time i
think he'd be a good villain to come
back to for a second like he's like in a
coma maybe or like the way that we
always wanted mordo to come back where
it's just like what are you off figuring
out what inside and then like what have
you done i would love mordo more than
others
does when you say it's morbid time does
not take you to jingle all the way it's
turbo time is that the joke no
it's from
uh
you are where they have that van and
they spray paint it maybe i'm just
thinking of true lies i don't know
anyways yeah but no there's one yes
because i was also thinking of tom
arnold um uh speaking of sinbad bad
batch season two coming september 28th
um we got that announcement we knew that
we were getting a bad bad season two
sometime this year but we got
confirmation september 28th that's gonna
be right kind of in the middle of andor
i believe those series are going to
overlap the end of august yeah into into
september that's too too soon too much a
lot of star wars in the late summer
early disney still seems to be stacking
everything on wednesdays i mean i know
they released the first uh uh obi-wan's
on a friday but that was kind of tied to
celebration but obi-wan and miss
marvel's going to overlap do you think
they're striving to like just have every
wednesday night own every day of the
week i think in like five years they
could easily do that yeah in ten years
they could own every minute of the day
five years every day oh my god
4 19 p.m oh my god or it's mickey
real quick can we do a poll in the chat
um of do this is just a question i've
always had do you watch the animated
star wars content like as it's coming
out like current yeah are you are you
watching this
oh you said star wars uh yeah star wars
animated content so clone wars and
that's kind yeah uh do you watch that
currently or whenever it gets airing
yeah and maybe even like do you watch it
as soon as it comes out are you kind of
a regular binger like you catch up on a
full season or something like that
dawson kind of figured out you like uh
uh never watched it i'm on i'm live
action ride or die um
the reason because it's it's because of
the felony angle now it's like becoming
more essential but it's also a little
bit like i think they they were going
after children when they first started
uh setting those up and then they tried
to age it up and i think a lot of people
like my age are a little bit like oh
do i need to now go back over there and
start that i missed i missed those first
couple things and now there's like a
pretty deep cannon of stuff to catch up
on yeah but it seems like increasingly
you want to know about these thrawn or
like wait oh there's always a ton of
ahsoka backstory right like i would like
to be a part of that maybe nine votes
pull complete
lock it down we know
speaking of star wars joby harold head
writer of obi-wan kenobi uh during an
interview mentioned he organically came
up with the whole end of episode two
riva disclosing that anakin is alive and
is vader while she's kind of like
hunting down obi-wan in that warehouse
yeah um that's interesting because
apparently that means i mean it was
okayed obviously by the the big brains
lucasfilm but it wasn't part of a grand
plan that's had that come out i think
that's the most interesting part is the
fact that they were about to write an
entire show and this big game changer
from the the two episodes we saw or
three episodes we saw was like not even
gonna be even addressed it's not gonna
be that was my guess was i was like of
course it'll be end of episode two he
finds out he literally said that he had
to go to pablo hidalgo and just be like
yo is it canonically do we know this do
we know this x y and z x y and z and
pablo was like no no yes no and he was
like oh so we should address it right
and he's like you can so it's like they
didn't even
most people don't that the ringer house
of our podcast that covered episode one
and two of kenobi they did a great job
of kind of breaking down who knows anna
kenneth skywalker it's a very small
amount and one of the great points they
bring up is all the way after like
return of the jedi anakin is darth vader
anakin and zach darth vader you said
skywalker oh
yeah anakin is skywalker is darth vader
right most people don't know that
obviously like the emperor but very few
people most of the inquisitors don't
know most of the people
involved in the empire don't know and so
much so after return of the jedi when
leia is
you would assume she would become like a
senator or some some person in the
government
one of her rivals like releases the fact
that her dad was anakin skywalker who
was darth vader it's a big scandal and
like ben solo didn't know and he finds
out during that and that's why he gets
pissed so it's like most people had no
idea it was a very well-kept
secret in fact
that he was related
but not because remember he says my
grandfather at some point in the movies
but he didn't know until he was like a
teenager yeah so right before force
awakens presumably because it was a big
deal because darth vader's a bad dude
and like the fact that leia was related
to him killed her political career and
that's why she became a general instead
of becoming like a politician do you
guys know anybody who
their grandparents were just straight-up
nazis uh
no i do know again
in my middle school his dad killed his
mom and that was like a big that was a
sad day oh my god and he was also he was
named after his dad which is even kind
of sad
that was tragic happy friday everybody
tell me why i thought yours was a bad
question mine was just so horrible
hey no you know it's a poll in the chat
no no no do you call in the chat did
your dad kill your mom
oh we did get a bigger pole
was it was teasing the poles that's why
that nine volt pole didn't count
how do you feel about the star wars
animated content uh it seems 44 percent
watches as it comes out this is our
beautiful live audience here live right
now we know they got that interesting
though but not at all 21 and binge it
later 17 which makes like you put those
together actually we're still lower than
the 44. i want to point out the flaw in
this poll uh the fact that it says do
you watch things as it comes out or
later and the people that are watching
this later are like i didn't have time
to watch it live
i mean i didn't watch a lot of clone
wars animated stuff because i'm an old
man and catching up on it it could be a
little rough yeah there's great lists
out there of like here's the ones that
matter you can skip around honestly
that's what i did too it's like these
are the good ones speaking of old voss
has a breakdown that just came out yes
old man boss has a story to have gosh
got a story to tell old man boss got a
story to tell he has a breakdown that
came out i think yesterday technically
right he has a breakdown yesterday came
out about three breakdowns episode three
breakdown about the third sister riva
and how sneaky she's being and how she
is definitely hiding something go ahead
and play me that clip and yeah you may
have noticed that before vader cut her
off riva was totally blaming obi-wan for
stabbing the grand inquisitor on daiyu
this shows that she doesn't want vader
and the other inquisitors to know that
she actively usurped authority and in
doing so she makes out kenobi to be a
more lethal threat than he actually is
right now i think especially after vader
duels that lightweight old man kenobi he
probably knows that riva was the one who
stabbed the grain inquisitor
okay so
in
it's kind of insane
in saying it's kind of insane i like
that she's hiding clearly like she
doesn't want
darth vader to know what she's done what
that she killed the grand exit right so
what is she what is she trying to get
from cuddling up to vader so much well
vader's like in charge of them but he
doesn't like the
inquisitors at all no he hates them
because the m the emperor put them
together and then was like all right
darth this is that you have to like lead
these guys he's like i hate these guys
because the sith as we all know there
could be only two right there's a master
and an apprentice but
at all times the master and the
apprentice are like making other ones
because they don't trust each other and
you're constantly worried that your
master or your apprentice is gonna kill
you so the fact that like the emperor
kind of shows his cards and like here's
uh an unknown number of apprentices and
these are four sensitive they're four
people like you sit there you want to
really like mess with somebody which is
basically the move he did it's like hey
zach i'd like you to be meet uh brandon
five
and you don't know how many players it's
like oh well and then yeah later you
meet like jessica thirteen and it's like
okay then how many people are out there
right here
jessica's or just five
[Applause]
how many are we cycling through these
people guys
i think it's morbid time whoa
hey again if you're just joining us uh
every time we hit 100 bucks in
super chat
the redemption is
we unleash one of the brand new morbius
songs that's getting added to the
soundtrack this weekend back in theaters
yes brandon and jessica through
corporate espionage espionage found the
lyrics are going to recreate the song
for you here live on the stream and and
just right before they do we'll pick up
this question of what is riva really up
to is what's she trying to pull off with
vader or whatnot on the other side of
the song so put your own theories in the
chat yeah so this song i found in the
cabinet of a chief sony officer wow um
the cso the cso oh my god it's written
by cardi b it's written by cardi b
that's a big get for more videos and
they didn't put it in that normal movie
wow
are you allowed to say what the name is
it's called
strong and bloody
certified creep
seven nights a week
strong and bloody milo wants a taste of
me
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah you messing with some dr
morgan bring your enemy in a vein for
some dr morbin bring your sister and a
cane or some doctor morbin that that's
all i could take
guys you gotta go back to the theaters
and see this movie you gotta tell that
song because maybe that song will be in
there is that right that's on this
soundtrack or he performs that stuff
i think he performs it in the movie and
then it's okay good so then he's the
character he calls himself doctor yeah
yeah it's morbid time yeah well cardi b
helped him write this song so i don't
think she knew who the [ __ ]
yeah thank you to all our super chatters
uh john boyer mr krabs ben mazur
pentamente really pushes over the top
there appreciate you and she did ask we
should answer her question well ask his
reva question but she asked if you're
all y'all i love y'all if y'all were
sith lords what would your name what
would your name be mine would be darth
titty wow
because i like to sit oh i just sit
there we're all problems we're all
problems for them grand muff tomper
oh my god
let's get back fired immediately hey
it's friday guys
this looks like a coke zero but we have
no idea what's in that can okay um so
yeah because what's riva's plan well i
love
i like to our thumbnail style question
what's her plan i love that ambiguity
and like it is interesting like showing
us that scene in her way moving obi-wan
it's a nice reminder of like oh yeah
she's not necessarily just a hand evader
out there doing his bidding she's off on
her own we know she's definitely not
down with the rest of the inquisitors
because she's uh stabbing them and
giving them side eye right and left
right like she's got her own agenda
separate from the inquisitors and
separate from vader i think she was
trying to cover for the fact that uh
obi-wan got away by saying that he
killed the inquisitor so he's that good
right
because
like we were saying uh darth doesn't
like these inquisitors so she should
have just been like yeah i killed him i
know you hate him don't worry about it i
think that she's playing him too playing
jargon yeah i know which because
because because because because i'm
trying i know i'm excited i'm excited uh
because she established clearly having a
personal vendetta against obi-wan and
then here where vader's like oh i know
what you're really after i know what you
really want to be the grand inquisitor
and it's like that's not what her
motivation was she said that it's
something specific about obi-wan so
she's letting him think that it's that
if she helped something else i think she
could hate both of them obi-wan and
darth vader because it's like why didn't
obi-wan save us but also darth is the
one that did it well and if this whole
theory that she's one of those uh
younglings or whatever that was you know
in the temple at that first shot we saw
at the beginning of episode one she
hates everybody responsible for that
she's definitely gonna hate darth
because he was leading the charge in
there right and she hates uh obi-wan for
not being there to save them right so
on to the breakdown video vos did talk
about something else that uh john
grabbed a clip of see if you guys can
see it there is a red room the room in
the spaceship that red line has the
child helmet craziest
and the light sabers and their lights
and that's in the inquisitor's room not
not vader's room yeah
so that's like all that could be all the
lightsabers of like the people they
stole and killed or
did you guys when you were watching a
breakdown or anybody at home when you
watched it break down at that moment go
like
i did yeah that was like
the helmet and it's like dark and it
still has the top of their heads in it
it's just underneath something it's like
a bowl cut but you think they get the
kyber crystals out of the white sandwich
those are valuable you could sell those
on the street they don't need to sell
anything on the street they're there
they probably have like a swirl
oh yeah
a great super chat that came up here um
oh woodruff saying you think that maybe
riva is a jedi who infiltrated the
inquisitors now that i was thinking that
that is a little crazy and i don't think
it's true but i love like the parallels
there because we just saw a good person
or you know a member of kind of the
resistance what's that character's name
that was impersonate tala impersonating
uh an empire officer right
i was really confused by the scene she's
either is an imperial officer who's also
helping the jedi or she just dressed up
but she said she did a lot of bad things
and she was like maybe yeah she was more
yeah she did make it seem like she was
part of the empire but that's what
confused me because i'm just staying
your outfit and be like i'm taking these
two away yeah end of the problem she's
like i don't know sneaking around i
guess
someone in the chat said or maybe those
lightsabers in the helmets are their
their own and we thought we definitely
thought about that i immediately was
like maybe they just hung it up when
they were children
i thought that but it's like there's so
many and not as many of them on that
ship so i think it's from the past
people they murdered um and also it's
such
other brothers and sisters
it emphasizes just how scary they are
well they're not
they're not sith because i know
when you when you turn sith or turn to
the dark side it turns your lightsaber
right it corrupts the kyber crystal but
if they're turning in their old ones and
then getting new ones are they
re-corrupting kyber crystals
program yeah
i need a two-hour long show
i do i do love that that detail is also
so great as you mentioned it's that's
heavy man that's that's serious that's a
little scary this is for a show that
it's kind of about like a grumpy guy and
a little girl you know traipsing around
the galaxy it can be a little like kind
of cute and pg like those are some very
nice that's what i do that's what i
talked about this i think either
yesterday or the day before i needed
something to push me over the edge to
really make me feel in the kenobi series
and that imagery like makes yeah i mean
the 66 killing kids start showing and
then seeing just all the numbers which
would give her reason to be against both
sides like every day i walk on this
freaking ship and see all my my brother
in that room she helped string up that
one uh well she because she's not loyal
to either side right i'm gonna give you
guys a pitch for the rest of the season
it does come out that she is essentially
working against all of them because
basically she's doing kill bill oh yeah
okay this is my list and these are the
people and maybe that list has a lot of
inquisitors on it too exactly yeah aria
list that she did too 100
i'm so into this i think there's a lot
to look for for
riva in the series a great new character
and a lot to follow yeah and this is
what i'm doing and we've only scratched
the surface on her right we don't even
know her full back story we're going to
get a lot more of you want her to be
redeemed by the end or do you want her
to stay the thing is what is the redeem
it's like killmonger right if her
justification is that like i'm i
recognize what she's doing she's not
trying to kill leia probably she's just
trying to lure out obi-wan because she's
been betrayed well we know most of these
people can't be killed yeah we know she
doesn't get greater she doesn't get to
kill obi-wan oh
supposedly a grand inquisitor is going
to be killed
oh that's terrible fair play yeah that's
a good chop lay in half you're talking
about you're gonna look at a red cotton
fillet leia's a robot the whole time
yeah just from here to here
oh yeah get our friend thunder all of us
could replace our abs with that i wish i
wish eliminate back pain
you know it doesn't eliminate back pain
but does help with your health in other
ways god you sound old
my sciatica
our good friends at athletic greens
thank you so much athletic greens for
sponsoring the show i've got a little
bottle of some ag-1 can we get some
shots while you talk about it
it's like we're at it's like we're at
the juice bar and we're getting our our
wheatgrass on here but uh got some shots
of ag-1 you know this
ag-1 has over 70 uh vitamins nutrients
all kind of the good stuff you need to
get through your day it's basically
nutritional insurance right maybe you
missed a meal or two maybe you just had
a candy meal who knows
cheers everybody happy friday yeah good
health to the man and may the women live
forever okay not be killed by their
husbands i'm gonna murder all of you ah
oh yeah um oh that is really good it's
like very easy yeah yeah and it feels
healthy it feels healthy in a nice way
right it's got minerals probiotics all
that good stuff is in there nice way to
get your day started right you just
mix up a little water and one of these
guys and you're kind of covered for the
day in a really nice way and
you can
start your kind of health journey
reclaim your health if you'd like today
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition by clicking that link in
the video description you don't need a
million different pills you don't need a
bunch of saxa stuff you need one sack of
ag-1 maybe stacks of stuff just exactly
i'm a thoughtless meat sack
this a nutrient dense
uh green batch we can get it at saks
fifth avenue oh
zach's with us
when you when you click that link and uh
sign up athletic greens is actually
gonna give you a free one-year supply of
a moon i keep want to say immune
supporting um i feel like a moon is like
maybe uh it's off of alderaan or
something
um
yes immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase head to athletic greens.com
break room that's athleticgreens.com
break room the name of this show take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
also makes us look great here at the
show yeah so if you like us and you want
us to stick around supporting our
sponsors is an awesome way you can do
that legitimately though like look on
their website all the ingredients this
is like everything you need including
probiotics like um
and we're also gonna do a plug for our
merch partners over at the epic hero
shop
i'm i'm repping one of the uh cool this
is kind of like a metal the the
metallica font here avengers shirt
brandon's got a similar kind of metal
what's his name say the name
confirmed uh shirt the cool thing about
epic hero they take you know the
properties we love and put them into
different styles they've got some fun
religious themed obi-wan shirts going on
right now we've got these like kind of
metal music real fun religious
like his father oh got him owen
put him down
and i also cannot reiterate enough that
i did i
my legs hurt from climbing to sony
headquarters
yeah don't breathe
yeah send in those super chats we stole
so many songs and cleaned so many
toilets yes they gave you these
to be clear i'm gonna bet that they're
not many of them are rap no they're not
they're they they span a genre this is
like
the soundtrack is like the fourth scene
so there could be all kinds of things
that are happening uh if you're a boomer
out there watching we got some old songs
for you some oldies if you're a young
person watching i think i got all the
songs for you
i also forgot to tease at the top now
this is absolutely 100 percent true and
there will be photographic evidence of
this nobody else can send it to this or
agree to this so i'm going to do this by
myself
and i just i'm going to lower the number
okay if we can hit three hundred dollars
no
by the end of this show
i will go watch more vias tonight at ten
days
now they're not gonna donate i will i
will take photos there actually i'll go
tomorrow night i have something going on
tonight i will go saturday night
at the burbank amc 16. stop it the 10
p.m showing of morbius anybody else that
wants to come can watch it with me
inviting them to fight you
they square up
d16 i'll have a coke zero and two fists
and uh uh we'll be ready to go but i
will we gotta hit 300 bucks i will uh
actually go and watch more obvious 10
p.m
he's been trying to get us all in and he
said if we reach a thousand maybe
and you know what i kind of want to go
see it so i just dropped it to 300 bucks
but you've got to get there you've got
to meet me in the middle chat uh 300
bucks and i'll go see morbius tomorrow
night and you guys may have noticed that
uh tommy's not here right now he
unfortunately is in prison uh he did he
did use his one phone call to call me
and he wanted me to say that it's time
for mandatory fun
hit the graphic
well he did he also traded in a ton of
honey buns to get a second call because
we play that graphic two times
play it again
tommy now uh we're raising money for his
legal defense but pro bono i will say
play it
that one's for free tommy no he's gonna
owe so many honey buns man he's gonna
know a ton of honey buns he only gets so
many honeybees i mean guys it's more of
a time here uh how are you
getting in jail fifty what's up what's
the conversion from the cigarettes to
honeybutton
people aren't smoking these days it's
bad for your health everyone's eating
hot
uh
so morbius has memed its way back into
the theaters whether the studio knows
what they're doing or not but this means
that the memes have the power guys and
with those memes we can bring our
favorite films back to the movies maybe
as a as a replay or or maybe as a new
sequel or or reimagining of our favorite
properties so we've made some memes to
get our our our favorite movies back
into theaters as a reminder you know
it's morbid time this was the name that
did it you guys did it the internet
finally did something right you really
you got more beats back in theaters the
may may that started a revolution
yeah yeah the maymay will be televised
the more man the more may that started a
revolution you guys are in the chat
thank you so much someone uh i think it
was mr krabs donated fifty dollars
tj jones just pushed us over the top
baby but somebody just put money into
pay
here's what i'll say we hit three but
300 bucks i'm going to go see more bees
we see we hit 400 bucks i won't see more
the prisoner's dilemma for all of you at
home how much do i super chat i don't
know there's a trolley track morpheus is
on one and also td jones thank you very
much also if you watch yesterday's
episode not only will i see more bs i
will uh sneak some inappropriate food
into the thing oh he'll take a panda
bowl
from pancakes i'll pour a panda bowl
into a ziploc bag that i will put in
some cardboard shakiness steamed some
asparagus
before we hit the memes we own another
song
i'll have one more song yeah get them
with them okay and again if you're just
joining us when we hit 100 uh multiple
in the chat it redeems we get to unlock
one of the new sondr soundtrack songs
for morbius uh they're parody style
weird al esque these are real these are
we will be in the movies please don't
all right this one they played a lot for
this one they played a lot for this they
they got they got the the rights to a
beatles song okay
from michael jackson's uh well maybe he
only bought some of them he didn't buy
all he didn't buy i don't know if he
bought this i don't think he did uh for
my boomers out there if you know a hard
day's night uh they've repurposed it for
morbius wow uh so get your tunes
together because it's been a hard day's
night
and i've been gliding
like a bat
it's been a hard day's night
i don't know where my milo's at
but when i get home to you and i chug
down some blue it will make me feel
all right
when i'm morphed everything seems to be
right
when i'm moved my face will be giving
you a bite
bye
lt's trying to get you to the 400 so you
don't see it
because
it's a real prisoner's delight okay
here's my meme i want to get edgar
tomorrow back in back in i love edge of
tomorrow
you know we got a top gun sequel finally
let's get it let's get back in there so
here's here's my meme for uh to get it
back in there uh i'm on the edge of
tomorrow and i'm hanging on a moment of
truth okay and if that's not good enough
for you my scientology head's out there
this one's for you okay you're a big
solid scientology fan you'll get this
one
when you when you add ot level seven and
they tell you there's an ot level eight
one quack oh good maybe
so i'm a big fan of starstrip troopers
if you guys know it which i guess uh
young people go check it out it's
ridiculous and they've made several they
haven't follow up don't worry about
they've not hit theaters they have not
hit theaters yes and yes remember to
watch the first one it's satire yeah the
first one's great don't don't live the
gimmick at the first time
my favorite scenes that stuck to me was
when the aliens sucked that guy's brain
right
so we did this one if you zoom in and it
says when you finish but they still suck
[Music]
sorry sorry kids
they don't know what they're doing don't
know what that means ask your parents or
don't or don't go look up the scene and
you'll get it
good that's
i got in trouble for my version of that
that i posted i liked i liked that a lot
that was a good one
i got stern talking too
okay i got one uh uh so i think that
just like when we were kids movies had
messages and they you know want us to
learn things and it turns out the world
is still dying so i want to bring back
fern gully
but just it's here you go
when your partner says you're toxic but
it's okay
cause that's your name you're toxic you
gotta have seen friend goalie for this
one to work yeah everyone is good
that's a good one
toxic love baby uh and then real quick a
movie i've seen on
dvd and or streaming but i didn't get a
chance to see it in theaters because i
don't think anybody saw it in theaters
that was john carter from mars one of
the most epic flops of all time uh so i
want
uh i want that to be brought back in the
theater experience men are from mars and
so are the women oh you know what else
is for the women oh what's that
oh did we just hit another redemption oh
my god jessica wait here i'm just gonna
real quick show the second john carter
maymay um what does this one say
uh
when she says she's on the red but
that's no problem
red planet i love it red planet i love
mars needs moms yeah
okay so now it's like you're also seeing
more bees
well right now i think we're still
calculating totals we're in the 300
range which means he's going as of right
now
right yeah confirm
300 i'm going 400 i won't go paint a
mentee put a lot of money into requiring
video evidence of you going and while
you're there loudly saying it's more
than oh yeah yeah he's got us yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah do a triple
h more than time
please don't get someone to record you
what are you into you're not gonna be
the only person doing that too
you will not be the only one after i
cleaned um the bathroom one of the
bathrooms right that was so nice of you
i went to there yeah until i went to
their uh kitchen to go get some food and
i saw this next to the coffee pot there
for too long i know so this one's
written by aretha franklin wow which i
wow don't understand i'm so surprised
and here i'll give you a taste
what you want oh
baby's got it uh
what you need
you know he's got it
all we're asking
is
baby i just gotta eat v-a-n-p-i-r-e
wow
i want a vampire in me
to me it's pretty
[Laughter]
who paid a lot to ask you not to do it
but well we're currently in the deal you
know what you we got to push it past 400
if you don't want me to go i have a i
have a family i have other things i need
to be doing with my time but i will go
see more b it's true okay he will he
will go see it uh just
just me had a super chat earlier where
he said and this is going back to the
rule of two with the sith before the
rule of two darth bane uh there were
sith academies and armies it wasn't the
first time the jedi temple was destroyed
he also loves the redemption idea oh
thank you justine well yeah
there used to be a lot of sith and i
think maybe that was the problem too
many sith so they had to narrow it down
to just two
and it seems like emperor palpatine uh
darcidius has maybe been in the old i
think he's been every dog that's kind of
an interesting parallel i'm bastardizing
i'm not as familiar with the lore so
there used to be tons of both we went
down to two sith and there was still
lots of jedi and then eventually we kind
of went down to just two jedi too right
like they kind of brought their numbers
down as well interesting i mean every
jedi is a potential sith you know that's
what i like about the jedi oh yeah the
jedi are evil maybe you live long enough
to see yourself become associated yeah
theodore harris uh saying please don't
yeah i assume that
please don't go see more bs i appreciate
you theodore maybe i'll try to see
another movie in addition maybe i could
see a different one declining smash did
say if you have to see morbius pay for a
different movie and sneak in
don't give sony any of those you gotta
get it to the billion dollar mark guys
we gotta get more beers
how far are we from the billion-dollar
market yeah yeah
yeah and if we hit a billion dollars in
the chat guys i will get a full back dat
of
okay i don't currently have any tattoos
i'll make myself whoever pushes us over
to the billion you can draw it
mr krabs had asked earlier what do you
what do you all think of darth grosgu
do we think grogo could eventually turn
evil well he'll live long enough he's
gonna lie and he's not he we don't see
him he's not taking the jedi helpful
stuff that's for sure later
we've seen that little touch of evil in
him yeah he loves to hurt he can do it
he's that little malice yeah yeah i ate
all those yeah i know that woman
eliminated an entire species that told
you not to he turned on the other
padawans
oh that'd be very interesting uh um oh
god what up mr krabs saying uh
500 bucks and you have to oh sorry i
just watch it twice back to bay
fair i will i will see the movie twice
if we hit 500 bucks
daniel john's asking just don't stay
home baby
battle for beauty saying please no
morbius but gotta try out the steamed
artichoke
if you're watching yesterday some people
take steamed artichokes so coy jandro
brings a steamed artichoke with him
jessica clemens brings an entire panda
express it's a panda bowl which is small
and it doesn't matter the smell is not
small the smell is that hey i'm just
saying it'd be more robust if it's a
three-car is it in the wrinkly panda
express bag and like you're just like oh
i take it out and put
this brings up a good point uh when we
went and saw multiverse of madness uh
opening night it was a packed house amc
offers a full range of meals which
philip will eat all of them they don't
have a kitchen back there stop buying
the full dinner
you don't need a car but if you order
enough stuff they give you like a
shopping bag to carry it in this person
sitting behind me kept reaching into
their gd shopping bag making so much
noise if you're gonna eat during the gd
movie get it ready and leave it out on
your lap
brandon amc needs to invest opera houses
make like un uh silent wrapping for like
cough drops and stuff like that that
they hand out yeah so there's no sounds
like they're all just like really wet
and like oily
i have had season tickets with the
pantene just multiple years and you know
it attracts an old crowd go see musicals
kids
but they do say please unwrap all your
treats or heart candies before get those
words originals out yeah looks like he's
not going down
400. mountain wayne begging don't go zac
don't go zach i've got roughly about six
to ten minutes left before it gets we
can get to 500 okay
and then we have to see it twice a day
another song we got another one yeah oh
yeah
do you want to do another one no i only
got you got like two no i got another
one i got another one here we go here we
go uh this is we both were like let's
only steal three yeah
let's both have a smart of you yeah do
you want to get your boys this was a
good one uh yeah when i was uh sweeping
up the hallway area i found this one
tucked behind a like a planet a potting
plant uh i don't know and this one
they're paying for my girl carly ray
jefferson god bless you gotta love carly
ray
she's not dead i don't know what a great
job i reanimated carly ray johnson
she just played coachella guys she's
doing great got a new single out western
wind love it uh
i'm it's a call me maybe cover of course
which she's got better songs than that
call me maybe it's great but listen
listen to emotion it's a great album
guys anyways uh uh this is uh what what
you will hear when zach goes to see
morbius again when we get him to 400.
okay he swings into the court someone
just donated
oh no okay i'll do my song right this is
call me morbin uh here we go by kyrie
jepsen the cave was holding bats with
blood aglow and now my fangs are growing
where you think you going milo hey i
just bit you
and this is crazy but i'm a vamp now so
call me more bee
it's hard to walk right without the
baddies
so call me morby hey i just bit you
and this is crazy but i'm a fifth now so
call me more b and all the other boys
they try to change me but i'm a vape now
so call me morby
our favorite sadistic viewer paintamenti
pushed us over the top
bless your heart paintamente it is in
fact morbid time and i will be attending
tomorrow night saturday june 4th at the
amc don't show up and fight him with you
at the burbank town center what's even
worse is he he's doing it on the day
he's off you guys are wow
i am not being compensated for this i
hate purchasing this i have a wife at
home who would love for me to be home
i will not be taking a dog
come on i will be there and if you're in
the los angeles area and would like to
join me
uh please tommy bechdel unfortunately is
at a wedding this weekend he won't be
there otherwise
he might drive back forward he might get
back here i got one i got one last song
that i stole i only stole three songs
you guys again i couldn't afford a
lawyer no i can now i can baby so uh
this song this song right here the
office dog was left there that night and
i thought it was gonna attack me but it
delivered this piece of paper to me oh
lovely and i at first i thought it was
just like a note that said like get out
but it actually was a song written by
lizzo
and i lizzo wrote on the soundtrack
to morbius are you guys ready for this
yeah yeah i'm ready for it all right
are you ready i'm ready for this i'm
about to read it i just had to look
closer at it yeah i didn't know i got
okay there you go it's morbid time in a
minute i'mma kill a friend or neighbor
or someone near me the power were uh i'm
not talking fun or pleasure i'm just
talking blood and torture because it's
my job because i care about all these
kids i'ma need to find some evidence
that what i'm doing is wrong i don't
think she knew what she was gonna write
at the end
it was strong start though
this is written exactly in jessica
clement's font
did you like it or not though
you're signed now i i happen to know
that six total songs were stolen now we
have not yet hit 600 but the chat has
been very generous today we appreciate
everybody that was super chatting that
was chatting in general should we break
them off for freebie
i don't know
i think we should i think we should
because it's like our farewell like
here's our
last episode of the break room
i stole all these for the break room you
know what how about uh this is a uh send
off to zach because this poor guy zach
he won't be the same he won't be the
same so
i'm going to shave his head
well this one i stole off right off the
csos desk the chief sony officers okay
this was his favorite song wow
from his favorite girl group the spice
girls got them all back together for it
all five of them got them back together
here they here they go this is if you
don't wanna be this might sound good
okay
if you wanna be my doctor you gotta eat
all my friends drinking up all the red
blood morbid mode never ends if you want
to be my doctor you have got to glide
drinking our blood is easy just chug it
down inside
or what you think about that now i hang
upside down
so you can handle my fangs are you for
real
your blood looks tasty i'll give you a
try
drinking up all your red then i'll say
goodbye
genres they spend a lot of decades even
i know it's gonna be a great time for
you
with all these songs
in that movie now yeah yeah yeah thank
you painter mentee
[Music]
he wanted a song from you phillip do you
have any songs
said jessica's was awesome
ouch yeah
[Laughter]
i want you to know that we both broke in
there for you guys yeah yeah it wasn't
just me yes uh legitimately both of
brandon songs uh like i i honestly felt
something i did three songs
[Laughter]
both of your songs that i felt something
were worth having done
zach how are we going to experience this
with you are you going to be posting i
will i will i will document it can i
take over the news there might be a new
rockstars maybe an instagram story
new rockstar hashtag new rockstars break
room if you are going to see morbius
this weekend yeah if you're if you're a
sick twisted soul like myself uh you
could not you there's plenty of you
could go see top gun maverick or
everything everywhere all at once or
whatever or you could go like me to see
morbius this weekend tag us okay i want
to see your pick of you um giving a
proof of life in the theater hold up
today's newspaper hashtag in our break
room
memes aren't memes aren't real hold that
up and uh um and again if you're in the
burbank area at 10pm maybe just meet me
in the lobby then go see a different
movie okay but i will be watching
morbius all right
if you're out there watch out for grand
moff chopper
thank you all this was a short week we
only did four shows this week uh but we
appreciate everybody that was with us
all week long we'll be back next week
for five episodes tommy's gonna be back
we'll see a little bit more if philip
will have some other special completely
out that's
right we'll see you the following week
after that you'll be back um but we'll
have maybe some other guests pop in and
out next week we'll be talking uh the
boys will be talking more obi-wan we'll
be talking finally we get miss marvel
released to the public next week it's so
fun it's so charming
if you're checking out the boys the boys
underground comes back on the channel
today i'm on the episode jessica's there
marina shows up again and we'll be
covering uh all the episodes of that
show every friday you i know you guys
have not watched i know you guys want to
talk about those first 12 minutes oh boy
on to the boys underground and talk with
us as we discuss what we saw in our
shooks
that first episode is a doozy
thank you all so much everybody have a
wonderful safe fun uh relaxing weekend
all right bye bye bye bye bye dog cam
duck ham on the way out
[Music]
you